c'est demain
vous avez déclaré élu monsieur jack
7 2
je veux c'est gagner quoi
mais 2015 pierre karl péladeau le chef
d'entreprise devient pkp
le chef du parti québécois vous m'avez
confié un mandat fort et clair faire du
québec un pays
la victoire de l'homme d'affaires ne
surprend personne trois adversaires ont
déclaré forfait les deux autres ont
mordu la poussière
mais qu'est-ce que plus que les autres
on vient d'un peuple de défricheur de
colonisateurs d'explorateurs des copés
in deux centres à sydney c'est pierre
karl péladeau le gestionnaire
milliardaire qu'on vient d'élire des
capes est un homme d'affaires
il connaît l'entreprise reconnaît le
leadership pour une fois qu'on a un
nombre d'affaires on le voit comme un
indépendantiste qui est riche
je pense mais si qu'on avait le droit
vous venez de me dire oui
sur la base de son bilan d'homme
d'affaires pierre karl péladeau mériter
la confiance des québécois
quand vous l'avez vu le point vers la
télévision là qu'est ce que vous vous
êtes dit ça m'a pas de plus et j'ai même
répéter une phrase j'aime bien celui
qu'il aime le point que celui qui baisse
les bras
la voyez-vous premier ministre
parfaitement
d'autres sont moins convaincus pire car
n'écoute rien il s'est tourné coûte rien
et si vos gérer mon économie je veux
juste lui et le gère mieux qu'il a gérée
quebecor depuis que son père la mort
c'est tout à quel genre de politicien
doit-on s'attendre de ce problème
décrivez leur os 3 me soit intelligent
visionnaire dégénéré et entêté est un
mollet
quand pierre karl péladeau entre chez
quebecor en 1985 le journal de montréal
vient de fêter ses 20 ans le chiffre
d'affaires de quebecor frise les 350
millions de dollars en 1989 pierre
péladeau confie à son fils une première
mission d'importance
l'acquisition de maxwell graphics un
géant américain de l'imprimerie
c'est mon fils pierre calka négocier
toute cette transaction là où l'on est
d'accord
pierre péladeau le père admirait
beaucoup le talent les talents
financiers de son fils mais ne le
provoque est toujours le
en rejetant ses idées alors plutôt que
d'avoir une connivence y avait comme une
une relation de compétition entre les
deux bernard bugeon a été l'adjoint de
pierre péladeau pendant six ans pierre
péladeau est quelqu'un qui aime cdu qui
aimait séduire qui aimait aussi être
admiré ou aimé de ses deux c'est jean
pierre carles lui imposer ses décisions
de par son titre de par son rôle de
propriétaire d'entreprise en 1992 sous
la gouverne de pierre karl péladeau le
journal de montréal décide d'implanter
de nouvelles technologies et de couper
le tiers des postes de précié de
typographe et d'expéditeur le journal de
montréal pour pierre péladeau était son
oeuvre de vie et il n'aurait jamais été
question de réduire d'éliminer les
employés parce qu'il les aimait alors
tandis que pierre carles voyait ça
plutôt comme une entreprise avec un
profit des pères un affrontement est à
prévoir avec les syndicats en janvier 93
quebecor signent un bail d'un an dans
cet entrepôt de cornwall en ontario et y
installe des princes et des ordinateurs
lui mois plus tard quand la direction du
journal de montréal décret d'un lock out
l'atelier de couloir les prêts à faire
le montage et une partie de la pression
du journal à la place des employés de
montréal
c'est le premier lock out dans
l'histoire de quebecor le père aller
dans la rue ils les syndics et les
employés en grève lui serrer la main il
lui disait monsieur péladeau monsieur p
comme on l'appelait et lui disant on
vous aime vous êtes le temps grand un
grand homme d'affaires move votre fils
là il ne vous fait pas honneur au
journal de montréal pendant que le père
serre des mains sur les lignes de
piquetage dans l'atelier le fils
complète l'impression du journal de
montréal avec les cadres c'est des
choses qui s'apprennent relativement
la production connaît tout de même des
ratés après cinq mois de conflit un
tribunal ordonne la fin du lock out
deux mois plus tard on annonce que
pierre carles déménage à paris pour
s'occuper du développement d'imprimerie
quebecor heureux quelqu'un m'a dit il y
à un canadien qui tâta en bas ce n'était
pas prévu
je suis descendu et c'était pierre car
antonio fernandez était pdg d'une grande
imprimerie espagnole ona eurent first
sceaux m
la première fois que je les ai vu il m'a
fait penser à un tigre il était très
dynamique
déterminés ils voulaient acheter la
compagnie
pierre karl péladeau achète la prairie
et stallion et antonio fernandez devient
son employé il était très exigeant
toujours en train de fixer de nouveaux
objectifs en quatre ans pierre karl
péladeau achètent des imprimeries dans
quatre pays d'europe et fait passer le
chiffre d'affaires d'imprimerie quebecor
europe de 40 à 600 millions de dollars
dans la presse européenne
on le compare à superman un héros qui
vole à la rescousse des imprimeries
déficitaire mais qu'est ce qui le
motivait heureusement ce n'était pas
l'argent ils étaient déjà assez riche
il voulait être le patron le pouvoir le
stimuler
non
le 2 décembre 1997 pierre karl péladeau
est rappelé aux pays d'urgence son père
est hospitalisé
il est dans le coma à la suite de
l'infarctus c'était pierre carde qui
était comme son ange gardien qui s'est
tenue continuellement à ses côtés
c'était étrange parce qu'avais je mets
une relation affectueuse auparavant mais
mais il ya eu à partir de sons de ce
combat une présence de pierre carles
tu verras que je me suis jamais
expliqués mais qui était pourtant rayée
pierre péladeau s'éteint le 24 décembre
1997 au retour du congé des fêtes
bernard bugeaud personnes emploi c'est
terminé nous n'avons plus besoin de toi
chez quebecor une nouvelle ère vient de
commencer
décembre 1998
ce n'est pas encore noël mais pour
pierre karl péladeau c'est tout comme
avec le président d'imprimerie quebecor
il vient de piloter l'acquisition de sun
media une importante chaîne de journaux
anglophones c'est surtout un grand jour
pour pierre karl péladeau le toronto sun
est l'équivalent torontois du journal de
montréal nous battre c'était
probablement le journal le plus rentable
de toronto à l'époque alors c'était un
atout de plus dans son jeu à l'époque
paul godfrey était pdg de sun media
pierre karl a fait une offre qui était
bien au delà de mes attentes
le national post titre que quebecor a
payé la lune pour le soleil
j'étais ravie je pense que je fais un
tour d'honneur autour de l'édifice
c'était une somme inespéré quelques mois
après l'acquisition pierre karl péladeau
devient président de quebecor à 37 ans
il est à la tête d'un empire une
quinzaine de quotidiens 150 hebdomadaire
une station de télévision des maisons
d'édition des magasins de disques une
compagnie de pâtes et papiers et 160
établissements liés à l'imprimerie dans
15 pays différents
mais pour le jeune péladeau ce n'est pas
encore assez
en juillet 99 quebecor annonce l'achat
de l'imprimeur américain world color
press
elle devient le plus grand imprimeur
commercial du monde
l'acquisition double la dette de
l'entreprise
mais le nouveau pdg ne semble pas
inquiet
pierre karl péladeau ne le sait pas
encore mais autre chose ce sera
l'acquisition de vidéotron en 2000
l'ontarienne rogers est sur le point
d'acheter vidéotron mais le vice
président de la caisse de dépôt et
placement du québec michel nadeau n'est
pas d'accord il veut que pierre karl
péladeau achètent des autres ont donc
c'était votre idée de proposer c'est pas
lui qui est venu non pas du tout c'est
moi tu as proposé il me dit j'ai pas
assez d'argent
alors je lui dis on va on va faire aider
dans ce sens mais tu vois vider toutes
tes posts tu vas me donner tout ce que
ton pour s'emparer de vidéotron quebecor
investi environ 3 milliards
la caisse de dépôt fait grimper son
investissement à 2,7 milliards
c'est un show dans l'inconnu est
incroyable dans les mois qui suivent la
transaction la bulle spéculative des
technologies éclate
en un an la valeur de l'action de
quebecor chute de 32 à 15 dollars et
l'entreprise et plus endettés que jamais
depuis le décès de pierre péladeau la
dette de quebecor à quadruples et
passant de 2 à 8 milliards de dollars
via cave pour être franche avec vous
depuis que lui et le pdg où il est en
charge ou l'actionnaire majoritaire de
quebecor la performance est très mauvais
la croissance un des pires taux de
croissance dans tous les compagnies dans
le domaine de communication et médias au
canada et en amérique de nord porte
quand l'homme d'affaires mitch garber
fait cette déclaration
ce n'est pas pierre karl péladeau qui
répond mais quebecor qui répliquent par
communiqué contrairement à ce qu'affirme
un monsieur comme les résultats de
quebecor sont extrêmement solides et
parmi les meilleurs de l'industrie
qu'en est il vraiment maurice gosselin
était jusqu'à tout récemment directeur
de l'école de comptabilité de
l'université laval
nous lui avons demandé de nous aider à
analyser la performance de quebecor sous
pierre karl péladeau il a suggéré un
exercice très simple on a investi 1000 $
à quebecor en 99 et on a fait la même
chose chez rogers chez bce telus des
transports voici comment quebecor se
compare au géant canadien du monde des
communications de 1999 à 2014
mon mieux alors qu on a investi dans
quebecor le 31 mars 99 bayrou 1796
dollars le 31 mars 2014 sur 15 ans ne
fait 796 n'a pas doublé notre maison et
si on compare justement avec d'autres
entreprises par exemple transcontinental
ben le mille dollars investis vos 2381
dollar
si on prend fait le même exercice pour
tennis bompas 2000 à 2668 temps là si on
regarde bce si belle un bel ouais on
passe de 1000 à 2986 que triplé et si on
regarde rogers et 31 mars 2014 mais mon
médard vont 4037 dollar vaut comparaître
sont absurdes je vous le dis en tout
respect
luc lavoie a été vice président exécutif
chez quebecor pendant huit ans est
conseiller de pierre karl péladeau
pendant 15 ans armé d'un argumentaire
préparé par quebecor il balaie les
résultats de l'exercice du revers de la
main
tembec sas est incomparable canwest
peut-être incomparable et est
incomparable donnera peut-être
incomparable cascades pouvait très
comparable mais poubelle tembec et
cascades sont dans les pâtes et papiers
enjoy canwest était dans le monde des
médias et dans nos rites et dans
l'imprimerie quebecor quant à elle
oeuvrait dans les trois domaines en même
temps et depuis 2000 elle a ajouté les
télécommunications à ses activités en
achetant vidéotron aujourd'hui 80% du
chiffre d'affaires de quebecor est lié à
vidéotron
c'est pour cela que dans l'exercice même
si aucune comparaison n'est parfaite
quebecor est comparé à ses concurrents
du monde des télécommunications
ça peut être apparaître comme une
comparaison boiteuse mais on sait qu'une
entreprise doit aussi se comparer au
marché en général par rapport au marché
comme un conte seront par louis hébert
et directeur du programme de maîtrise à
l'école des hautes études commerciales
et si on se compare par exemple au tsl
et 10 la bourse de toronto
ce qu'on voit en face que les chips les
chiffres semblent vouloir dire c'est que
la performance de l'action de quebecor a
été inférieure à celle du marché
effectivement mille dollars investis à
la bourse en 1999 vaudrait 2173 dollars
en 2014 alors que 1000 dollars investis
dans quebecor ne voudrait que 1796
dollars réparti ce parce qu'on s'est
transformée et mais on sait transformer
le marché s'est transformée ou si des
entreprises se sont transformés sur le
marché
la composition de l'indicé s'est
transformée
quebecor a connu des périodes difficiles
sous la présidence de pierre karl
péladeau le chiffre d'affaires de
quebecor a grimpé de 8 à 12 milliards de
dollars pour ensuite chuter à 3,6
milliards de dollars
le nombre d'employés a plongé de 60
milles à 15 milles jusqu'à quel point
pierre karl péladeau est il responsable
du meilleur et du pire de ce cheminement
c'est un chasseur de têtes qui m'a
recruté
et ça m'a amusé parce que on me contacte
est toujours pour des maisons luxe des
grandes marques de luxe et là on
m'appelle pour un challenge industriels
à paris vincent bastien a été directeur
général chez louis vuitton et président
chez yves saint laurent en 2000 et est
embauché pour devenir président de
quebecor world europe
à l'époque c'est la crise dans
l'industrie de l'imprimerie entre autres
parce que le développement du numérique
fait chuter la demande
donc il va donc grosse crise de
l'imprimerie faudra gérer pour tous les
coins mais une opportunité de repenser
complètement le métier est de faire de
quebecor world qui était déjà le leader
ont chiffré en taille d'en faire au plus
le leader conceptuelle du marché donc ça
m'a beaucoup activée
vincent bastien garde de bons souvenirs
de sa première rencontre avec pierre
karl péladeau et j'ai vraiment
sympathisé avec me dis moi ça
m'intéresse plus du tout d'imprimerie et
je suis très content à la pierre carles
moi j'ai pas l'accent canadien
je suis très content qu'il ait embauché
pour que tu t'occupes de ce donc c'était
très bien en espagne ici les défis sont
grands mais les choses se passent bien
j'étais très impressionné par pierre
carles et très heureux que quebecor est
acheté la compagnie ou la chimie entre
nous et à bonn inscrits aux pires cas
les choses se corsent
en 2001 quand un ralentissement mondial
de l'économie
accentue la crise dans l'industrie de
l'imprimerie once on s'est rencontrés
une fois l'aéroport de barcelone je lui
ai dit pierre carles
tu es plus mince qu'avant il m'a regardé
et m'a dit tu ne sais pas qui je suis
maintenant j'ai senti qu'il avait changé
je crois qu'il subissait beaucoup de
pression mieux il était plus stressés
plus impatients brazil's au québec aussi
les temps sont durs la récente
acquisition de vidéotron a fait exploser
la dette de quebecor pierre karl
péladeau doit couper dans les dépenses
on est en campagne il faut juste
compagnie le choc est brutal entre les
deux cultures d'entreprise
c'est une compagnie ou sa vue c'était
l'époque une blague pour ses comptes
entre nous mais c'est vrai on pourrait
attendre deux heures sur la ligne
on ne se répondent c'est avec luc lavoie
que pierre karl péladeau s'est attaqué à
la restructuration de vidéotron on a eu
peu près deux heures et demie après midi
jeux vidéo tron est un immense parking
et c'est un camion de vidéotron plaît à
12h30 d'après midi le flex de pire qu'un
on achetait une peur panique parking
autres qu'est ce que c'est quoi la fait
et je me souviens que l'explication il y
avait quelque chose du genre
on a réalisé que quand chaque technicien
a son propre camion et en compte le soin
et non seulement ça on a fait installer
dans chaque un petit micro ondes de v
cloud
souvient lève on ressort dit l'ouvragé
en question provoque une grève doublé
d'un lock out
plus de 2000 employés de vidéotron passe
un an sur le trottoir du côté des
cadeaux si ça joue dur
le président de vidéotron et sept des
huit membres de la haute direction de
vidéotron télécom ont entamé des
poursuites après avoir été licencié
ils soutiennent qu'on les a flouées de
plus de 6 millions de dollars au total
en évoquant de faux prétextes pour ne
pas leur verser l'entièreté de leur
indemnité de départ
tous les dossiers se sont réglées au
recours mais le jeu vous prend vous
voulez jamais là-dessus je dise que
c'était l'histoire d'une compagnie comme
ça c'est tellement anecdotique que ça
nulle christ sa non parce que ça ça
dénote comment traite les gens chez
quebecor gens sont extrêmement les
conflits de travail sont pourtant
nombreux de deux mails à 2012
quebecor a été l'entreprise québécoise
où le plus grand nombre de jours de
travail ont été perdues en raison de
grèves
de lock out
pendant que le conflit sévit chez
vidéotron de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique c'est l'affrontement
il y à 12 jours que les palettes brûlent
devant l'imprimerie quebecor et quebecor
nous ont repris ils ont bien eu des
licenciements et à 6 ans et on continue
on en fait des licenciements
plusieurs imprimeries françaises acquise
par pierre karl péladeau sont
déficitaires et la restructuration est
plus difficile que prévu donc city chic
savait très facile à dresser
si je fais cela nord américain je vire
les gens jeu mais d'autres machines tout
va bien se passer
le problème c'est qu'ils les avaient
achetés pas cher pascal problème social
c'était quoi le problème social les
syndicats de l'imprimerie en france pour
licencier pour re re re structurés il
faut juste se donner du temps
c'est à dire que si vous donnez un nom
pour restructurer sa passe on a moins on
peut pas et qu est-ce qu à pied à kaka
s'est tout de suite tout de suite tout
de suite dans cette usine de mary sur
marne en banlieue de paris
le superviseur hervé ben ali se souvient
très bien de pierre karl péladeau parce
qu'on a tous vécu un moment donné
c'était les éclats de les éclats de
colère spectaculaire soit pour montrer
chu le patron parce que quand on a un
souci
c'est pas en criant fort très fort et en
claquant la porte on va résoudre le
problème en 2003 pour la première fois
de son existence
quebecor world termine l'année avec une
perte nette des quelque 150 usines à
travers le monde celle de la france sont
particulièrement déficitaire vincent
bastien est congédié c'est qu'en fait on
peut pas travailler que pierre caroff
sous les ors de percale c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible pourquoi
celles ci ont pas possible parce que il
veut qu'on obéisse strictement à tout ce
qu'il dit
ces liaisons lesniak qui prend la
direction des opérations françaises
je pense que yvan était prêt à accepter
de pierre cas ce que je n'étais pas prêt
à accepter je le point de vue que
lorsqu'on est des dirigeants salariés
on doit être des bons soldats et quand
des bons soldats doivent se faire
engueuler l'excusé mal terme
eh bien écoutez priori s'ils sont pas
satisfaits ils s'en vont mais sinon on
continue son job courageuses ont du
courage
yvan lesniak en a besoin les centaines
de licenciements provoque de violents
conflits
le président est séquestré à de
nombreuses reprises par des employés
mécontents
j'ai bénéficié d'un record 10,9 sur le
sujet en ouvre séquestration j'ai eu
droit à une protection de proximité
policière importante
j'avais bien sûr des gens qui me gardait
la nuit chez moi et des maîtres chiens
dans mon jardin etc c'est en acceptant
malgré les difficultés yvan lesniak a
toujours été solidaire de pierre karl
péladeau il est doté d'un courage
exceptionnel que j'ai rarement rencontré
chez les hommes très courageux très
déterminé
le courage et la détermination n'ont pas
suffi pierre karl péladeau n'a pas
réussi à remettre les opérations
françaises sur le chemin de la
rentabilité en amérique du nord
il a fermé des usines moderniser des
équipements et fait des milliers de
mises à pied mais là non plus ça n'a pas
suffi
en janvier 2008 le monde est en pleine
crise financière
quebecor world est étranglé par sa dette
et incapable d'obtenir un nouveau
financement
quebecor perd ses imprimeries aux mains
de ses créanciers
on estime que ses actionnaires y compris
pierre karl péladeau ont perdu près de 2
milliards de dollars dans l'aventuré
antonio fernández a été témoin de
l'ascension et de la chute de quebecor
world
selon lui l'entreprise a été victime
d'une croissance trop rapide
nous n'avons pas eu le temps de faire ce
qui devait être fait il y avait une
nouvelle acquisition tous les trois mois
il soulève aussi l'absence d'une équipe
solide et stable à la tête de quebecor
world en six ans ces présidents se sont
succédé nous n'avions pas une bonne
équipe de direction capable de prendre
les bonnes décisions au bon moment parce
que pierre carles voulez gérer trop de
détails et trop d'aspects de
l'entreprise lui même des business
quelles sont les erreurs des
gestionnaires qui a commise à la phase
d'accumulation des actifs a été trop
long on ne voulu rester au sommet trop
longtemps sans réaliser que la presse
écrite et sur yon pas beaucoup de gens
qui l'ont vu pas beaucoup jalons veut
que la presse écrite c'est beau jour
était terminée l'ancien président de la
caisse de dépôt est très fier
aujourd'hui d'avoir incité pierre karl
péladeau a acheté vidéotron parce que
sans vidéotron quebecor serait le white
star aujourd'hui une entreprise qui
végète dans la presse écrite et des
hebdos régionaux la quebecor est bien
positionné et dans la téléphonie
d'internet
vidéotron a bien prospéré sous la
gouverne de pierre karl péladeau elle
représente à elle seule aujourd'hui 97 %
du bénéfice d'exploitation de quebecor
la seule ombre au tableau c'est que
l'investissement de la caisse de dépôt
et placement du québec qui a permis à
quebecor d'acquérir vidéotron a mis plus
de douze ans a récupéré sa valeur c'est
l'équivalent pour la caisse de dépôt
d'avoir fait un prêt sans intérêt de
plus de 3 milliards de dollars à
quebecor pendant toutes ces années
non le ramenez pas été au rendez vous
durant dix ans mais je pense qu'à partir
de maintenant et au cours des deux trois
dernières années on voit que quebecor
des collègues
l'investissement de la caisse de dépôt a
finalement commencé à fructifier
quebecor s'est départi de certains
actifs moins performant entre autres
l'ensemble des quelque 170 journaux et
publications anglophones ont été vendus
et sun tv news
la station d'information continue de
toronto qui n'a jamais été rentable a
été fermé c'est un peu comme si quebecor
avait décidé comme son ex président de
tourner le dos au canada
et eu beaucoup de travail il quelques
controverses tu es beau tu es beau mais
je pense que tout le monde aujourd'hui
ça fait l'unanimité
plus on est très fiers de cette citerne
septembre 2015
le centre vidéotron québec ouvre ses
portes au public pour la première fois
sur la patinoire pierre karl péladeau
est assis aux côtés du maire labeaume et
de l'ex premier ministre charest voici
vous l' attaque chef du pq chef de
l'opposition à ces boss de quebecor
c'était quoi vous écoutez moi je sais
pas pourquoi je t'invite il su que
j'étais ici alors ça péladeau ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'on se demande
quel chapeau porte pierre karl péladeau
dans cette rue qui parce que c'est
l'actionnaire de contrôle de quebecor au
seul chef d'opposition chef du parti
québécois la double identité
professionnelle de pierre karl péladeau
pose un défi particulièrement quand il
est question d'économie
il faut faire en sorte de combat tous
les moyens les instruments qui sont
donnés aux entreprises pour ne pas payer
leur tribut à l'impôt le politicien est
contre l'évitement fiscal un souci la
position de l'homme d'affaires alain
deneault prêta de vos compagnies ont
déjà vu à faire avec les paradis fiscaux
mais je pense que ce soit utile
non je passais quebecor ici j'ai un
souvenir
sujet
la réponse est venue après le débat lors
d'un point de presse
db camp sous la direction n'ont jamais
eu de filiales dans les paradis fiscaux
la déclaration nous a étonnés nos
recherches nous ont permis de trouver 33
compagnies et succursales qui nous ont
semblé en lien avec l'empiré quebecor
pour 21 d'entre elles nous avons réussi
à établir un lien clair avec quebecor
world
quebecor affirme que cinq autres n'ont
aucun lien avec quebecor et ses filiales
qu'une seule avait un lien avec quebecor
media mais qu'elle n'a jamais été
utilisé et qu'elle est démantelée pour
les six dernières dont les noms
contiennent des expressions qui décorent
quebecor world who work over quebecor
déclare qu'elle ne peut ni confirmer ni
infirmer leurs liens avec quebecor world
parce qu'elle n'est plus actionnaire de
contrôle de la filiale depuis 2008 nous
avons demandé à trois experte de nous
aider à tracer un portrait de la
fiscalité de l' empire quebecor les
latulippe est professeur de fiscalité à
l'université de sherbrooke
allison kristen est professeur en droit
fiscal à l'université mcgill que ça veut
dire c'est qu'ils ont en place une
structure qui leur permet de faire des
planifications pour réduire les coûts
et brigitte alepin et fiscalistes et
auteur de deux best seller portant sur
l'évasion et l'évitement fiscal qu'on
voit une société comme quebecor et on
voit en lice comme ça puis on voit dans
les documents des planifications
fiscales compte de grands bureaux de
comptables internationales qui ont
intervenu au fil des années on honore le
sourire ça nous semble qu typique de
planification fiscale
rien ne permet de conclure que quebecor
ou sa filiale quebecor world se soit
livré à de l'évasion fiscale une
pratique frauduleuse
on semble plutôt avoir affaire à ce
qu'on appelle de l'évitement fiscal
c'est totalement différent de l'évasion
et le c de la planification avec les
règles en place on utilise les règles en
place au canada donne tout se dérègle en
place dans ces paradis fiscaux là et
c'est pour ça qu'on met des compagnies
dans les paradis fiscaux c'est parce
qu'ils ont un régime et ont des règles
qui nous permettent de faire des
planifications donc c'est légal mais ça
soustrait de l'impôt au trésor québécois
présents canadien clairement tout à fait
nous avons trouvé deux compagnies qui
avaient un lien avec quebecor world à la
barbade
on peut imaginer que yo probablement eu
des transactions d'évitement fiscal qui
utilisent la barbade qui fait en sorte
qu' on va stationner du revenu et ceux
revenus là
est imposé un faible taux s'ils n'ont
pas imposé du tout et ce qui est magique
avec la barbade c'est qu'on peut
rapatrier ce revenu là au canada les
bretons
nous avons aussi trouvé des compagnies
et des succursales en suisse au
luxembourg en irlande au panama et dans
les îles vierges britanniques des pays
où quebecor world n'avait pas
d'imprimerie voilà comme pdg de quebecor
dont qui est une holding et quebecor
média qui est une entreprise et c'est ce
que j'ai dit je n'ai pas créer deux
sociétés dans des paradis fiscaux
c'est exactement ce que j'ai dit ce
n'est pas tout à fait ce que pierre karl
péladeau a dit pendant la course à la
chefferie
il a dit que sous sa direction quebecor
n'avait jamais eu de signal dans les
paradis fiscaux
pourtant plus de la moitié des entités
que nous avons trouvé et qui ont un lien
très clair avec la filiale imprimerie
ont été créés pendant qu'il était
président de quebecor à l'époque
quebecor était la société mère
l'actionnaire de contrôle de quebecor
world et pierre karl péladeau a été vice
président du conseil d'administration de
la filiale quebecor world
mais vous quand vous étiez
administrateur chez quebecor world vous
saviez pas qu'elles avaient des
structures comme ça des d'évitement
fiscal oui je le savais mais c'est pas
parce que je le sais que j'ai le pouvoir
de desbin on va changer selon pierre
karl péladeau a aussi été président de
quebecor world pendant deux ans de 2004
à 2006
c'est pour lui que fait les
planifications mif en tant que président
de
d'un organisation le portrait global de
l'organisation il faut qu'ils soient
capables de l'endosser les compagnies
ses succursales de quebecor world dans
les paradis fiscaux
ont-elles servi à faire de l'évitement
fiscal il est impossible pour nous d'en
faire une preuve directe non c'est
possible
un passé mais cause du secret bancaire
non à cause de de la loi du canada et du
québec
des chercheurs comme force one ii nous
nous sommes demandé combien l'empiré
quebecor avait payé d'impôts pendant que
pierre karl péladeau était président je
pense que la meilleure façon de faire
l'exercice finalement fait deux semaines
dans les chiffres
puis essayer de voir qu'est ce que les
chiffres nous disent ils
brigitte alepin a étudié les états
financiers consolidés de quebecor il ya
des années où est ce que quebecor
faisait des bénéfices de 2 600 millions
de dollars 500 millions de dollars qui
avait un ratio de 4 %
c'est très peu elle a évalué que de 1999
à 2012
l'impôt payé par l'empiré quebecor
représente 12% de son bénéfice net de
plus de 3 milliards de dollars pendant
la même période
pour l'ensemble des entreprises
canadiennes le ratio a été de 22%
la carrière de gestionnaire de pierre
karl péladeau qui devait constituer sa
force
deviendra-t-elle son talon d'achille si
des gens ne vois pas aujourd'hui la
bombe à retardement que c'est pour le
parti québécois pour sa capacité de
reprendre le pouvoir
je serai le seul à le dire que je
continuerai à le répéter pendant la
course à la chefferie jean françois
lisée a été un des seuls péquiste a
soulevé le problème des conflits
d'intérêts potentiels à moi je pense
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui doit avoir le
crains de le regarder dans les yeux
désir car car ça marche pas ça n'a pas
de bon sens
michel david chroniqueur au journal le
devoir analyse la scène politique depuis
trente cinq ans monsieur péladeau soit
premier ministre s'il doit décider si on
donne nous retire des crédits d'impôt
l'audiovisuel une politique du livre etc
monsieur péladeau qui oeuvrent dans tout
ce secteur là se trouve en conflit
d'intérêts un ministre à la limite peut
se retirer des discussions du conseil
des ministes mais le pôle premier
ministre une autre enjeu c'est la nature
des avoirs de pierre karl péladeau parce
que c'est normal des deux chefs de
partis et de contrôler le principal
média au québec
ma réponse est non écoutez on parle de
la séparation des pouvoirs entre le
judiciaire et l'exécutif le législatif
les musées le quatrième pouvoir s'en est
un autre qui normalement pas normalement
absolument ne devrait pas interférer
avec avec un des deux autres parce qu'à
perversion des démocraties naftal un
rapport du centre d'études sur les
médias de l'université laval publié en
décembre 2015 révèle que 62 % des
québécois considèrent qu'il est
inacceptable d'être à la fois chef de
parti et actionnaires de contrôle d'un
grand groupe de médias d'information
selon michel david les libéraux
entendent bien profiter de la situation
ils veulent que ça devienne un enjeu la
prochaine élection ils veulent surtout
pas forcé monsieur péladeau à choisir
entre son empire et la politique parce
qu'ils veulent que monsieur péladeau
soit leur prochain adversaire à tort ou
à raison il estime que c'est un
adversaire qui sera pas très redoutable
l'avocate de potes c'est mon équipe je
ne commenterai pas sur les rumeurs de
journaliste c'est ce que voulait que je
voudrais pas de quatre fois sur le fait
si vous souhaitez le problème de
monsieur péladeau c'est son caractère
qui a l'air et son manque de jugement
politique jusqu'à présent en tout cas il
ya beaucoup de bons conseils qui
manifestement il n'a pas écouté et qui
devrait écouter
finalement le pire ennemi de monsieur
père de monsieur péladeau s'est pas les
libéraux sais pas monsieur couillard
c'était super dadoun humain
notre autonomie en question la qualité
d'un gestionnaire de pierre karl
péladeau avant tout le monde en parle
peut-être j'étais naïf mais je pensais
pas que attaque et pierre karl péladeau
se fait pas je savais pas au cours de
nos recherches nous avons fait une
quarantaine de demandes d'entrevue
auprès d'ex collaborateurs de monsieur
péladeau
pensez-y rats pour moi seul luc lavoie
et paul godfrey sont venus devant nos
caméras
il reporte bac et seuls les européens
pour accepter de partager publiquement
un point de vue critique
le président du conseil d'administration
de quebecor et quebecor et pierre karl
péladeau ont refusé de nous accorder une
entrevue
même chose pour jean françois lisée qui
n'avait pas oublié le froid qu'avait
jeter ses déclarations
la royal mail après les événements il a
écrit sur son blog
jamais de toute ma vie on ne m'a autant
sommet de me taire mitch garber de son
côté s'est fait attaquer sur les réseaux
sociaux
mais il ne regrette rien ça causait le
débat que j'aurais voulu causer le gpat
planifie pour pour ces affaires là où
pour la tempête mais le débat je pense
que cet important débat sur qui est toi
à part le nom le nom de famille à part
héritiers tuer qu'ils tuent veut gérer
un province est un pays
qu'est ce que tu as fait pour être
capable de le faire pourquoi tu voles
bien faire tuer qui à part le nom enlève
le nom qui ait du sens la question